give us your thoughts on how much the
questions that are being raised by VW in
the United States and the tip of the ice
but what does this mean for Europe I
think they're the tip of the iceberg
here in Europe we've seen a similar very
big gap between the official test
results which happen in a laboratory and
the way that cars actually perform on
the road in terms of their nitrogen
oxide emissions a study we launched last
week showed that just one in ten new
European diesel cars was meeting the new
regulatory limits that every vehicle
should have met on the first of sep
tember this year and some vehicles were
producing substantially more pollution
than what they were permitted to we're
talking about 10 or 20 times and the
questions therefore how are these
vehicles passing their laboratory tests
when they're performing so poorly on the
road so I would be very surprised if we
didn't see over the the forthcoming days
and months more manufacturers identified
as fitting these types of defeat devices
to trick the tests if that turns out to
be the case and we're dealing with
millions of cars what should the correct
response be to that the pollution that
is produced by these diesel engines is a
is a major issue for European
governments right now what response
should those governments generate as a
result of this well the pollution
generated is is leading to the premature
deaths of over half a million Europeans
every year it's costing the European
economy nearly a trillion euros and
certainly in the UK they recently said
that eighty percent of the problem in
cities was coming from diesels so the
diesel engine is a huge contributor to a
massive public health crisis in Europe
and I think the response from
governments is is very clear and indeed
from the European Commission we need to
have a really thorough investigation to
identify all of the ways in which these
defeat devices are being used
all of the manufacturers which are using
them they may not be limited just a
diesel cars but secondly we really need
the existing testing system tightened up
enormously in Europe we don't test the
same cars that people actually buy the
tests are completely unrepresentative of
the way the cars are driven on the road
and the people that do the testing are
paid for by the manufacturers and so are
those that oversee the tests we need an
independent regulator in Europe like we
do in the US this is the why this is the
reason the US authorities identify this
problem whereas in Europe we sell 50
times more vehicles but it wasn't found
here so Greg who are you calling on to
take action in this in Europe then I
think it has to be a lead from the
European Commission they have the
responsibility to bring forward new
regulations as part of the system of
type approval through which all vehicles
are are checked as fit for purpose
they're the people that must first take
action but I think there's an important
responsibility on the car industry also
VW has actually been very open since the
initial disclosure that they were
fitting these devices i'd like to see
other parts of the car industry be as
opens VW acknowledge the fact that they
are also using these technologies and
then we can begin resolve the problem
and move on I have to cut you off Greg
Archer thank you very much indeed for
your time